[Music]  there's daisy dukes and then there's  daisy dukes on Jennifer Aniston's part  of my job is to wear the clothes and  then I see how people respond the people  have spoken Jen consider us impressed I  think that's great  check out the 49 year old actress on the  set of her new film murder mystery in  Lake Como Italy  Jen rockin denim cutoffs showing off her  seriously toned legs the blonde beauty  with snap smiling and laughing as she  strolled with her hairstylist Chris  McMillan and a few other crew members  it's a good thing cute casual or dressed  to the nines there's no denying Jen  always looks stunning it's a very  special special thing so I'm really  excited  [Music]